level but you never gonna get back
please always push it up to the brain
breathe never expect your respect back
reach reach the keys you'll be size 10
[Music]
if you've been following the podcast
that me and my friend talk we do
watching the Watchmen
then you know I'm quite protective over
how the property is used after the
middling film and absolutely dismal
before Watchmen many fans think this
franchise should be left alone for
better or for worse DC have decided to
inaugurate the Watchmen franchise into
the DC Universe and pick the hero side
by side tease with the launch of DC
rebirth we began to see the two revered
franchises intertwine many fans asking
questions and giving theories on exactly
what was gonna happen down the line it's
the comedian the Joker will Superman
fight dr. Manhattan can night I'll still
get it off
there were hundreds one of these
additional less interesting ones was
what is the comedian's badge doing in
the Batcave this graphic novel attempts
to answer that following Batman and the
flash we journey to solve the
head-scratching questions boiler alert
it doesn't answer it at all taking
elements from flashpoint which is
another book I absolutely adore this
book will join the two critically
acclaimed franchises together and either
make every comic book fans wet dream or
worse nightmare which will it be
can this huge risk payoff or will they
ruin two of their best franchises in the
process let's jump into by now getting
off to a phenomenal start
we joined Batman in the Batcave as he
ponders over the mystery of the button
it's not a button it's a badge in the
background here's gspn on playing hockey
I have no idea why the Caped Crusader is
watching a hockey game while it's doing
his crime-fighting but I suppose all of
us have our sad little hobbies at least
he doesn't film comic book reviews for
YouTube that no one watches anyway at
this moment the reverse-flash shows up
firmly [ __ ] is my second favorite
villain in the DC Universe it's great to
see the return of the night or speedster
after dying in flashpoint have been
desperate for the Flash's favorite ball
to return
and the ensuing battle that he has with
the Dark Knight is a thrilling one
taking up the entire first issue we see
how the two would deal with one another
in combat and basically Batman gets the
crap kicked out of them knowing that the
flash will arrive soon
The Dark Knight merely has to delay the
reverse-flash until backup arrives
however after noticing the button it's
not a button it's a badge the
reverse-flash picks it up disappears for
a second and returns screaming that
years witness god
he drops down dead and it's here that
the true mystery begins opening the book
an outstanding fashion this first
chapter really grabs your attention
reminding me Ozymandias versus the
comedian in the original source material
it two sets of a mystery that really
makes you want is dive deeper into the
rabbit hole after Batman recovers he and
flash travel through the multiverse to
uncover as many clues as they can we get
a beautiful trip through the JLA
Watchtower viewing many of the trophies
they've collected through the heirs it
sort of signifies that the duo have a
rich history together and in the same
way that DC r now hardening back to the
Watchmen nostalgia is used to make farm
boys go crazy it was a nice touch if not
a little harvested in it hey hey
remember Starro the Conqueror a member
hey remember Watchmen sort of way one of
the most memorable and poignant moments
from flash point was when Bruce's father
Thomas gave flashing letter to give to
his son in the alternative reality it
was a touching moment that didn't really
need for the characters to meet in order
to have a connection and understanding
of one another DC against my judgment
decided that the two characters should
meet in this issue what I heard about it
originally I was very angry I'm happy to
say that I was wrong when the two meet
it's a really emotional moment it's so
touching almost brought a tear to my eye
as a reader I have a lot of thing
I would like to say my father but
probably never will the paradox of being
a human wanting to shower emotions also
wanting to safeguard them as well so
it's really gripping to see Bruce
finally get the chance to say all the
things that he wanted to say though it's
short-lived it's definitely one of the
books emotional high points and it
elevates this story above most modern
comic group ones when the flashpoint
world gets destroyed Bruce and the flash
must travel back to their earth through
the timestream and they bump into the
reverse-flash moments before he was
murdered
as with most time-travel centric stories
the protagonist and advertently caused
the element that drove them to
time-travel in the first place
this is no different they boss
reverse-flash to meet with the
mysterious god character which is weary
inevitably beats his death we never
really get a solid answer on exactly
what happens and honestly the book
leaves you asking more questions by its
end than you were at the beginning we
fade out to dr. Manhattan picking up the
button it's not a button it's a badge or
rating a quote from Watchmen and the
yellow and red a bit transforming into
the Superman logo teasing the next story
in the saga the Doomsday Clock Batman /
the flash coal on the button it's not
fun it's a bad doesn't ruin Watchmen or
flashpoint I'm happy to say but it also
adds very little to the mythos acting
Morris fan pictured it slightly misses
the mark on some elements but overall it
does a hell of a lot more good than it
is bad it still leaves me wanting to
know answers even though they've got the
potential of massively disappoint so I
suppose that's a positive for now
featuring stellar art there's very
little that I can fault this book on and
the meeting between Bruce and his father
is worth the price of admission alone
especially if you loved flashpoint
that's why overall I'm given this book
an 8.5 out of 10
so what did you think of the graphic
novel comment below let me know make
sure that you subscribe to my youtube
channel because like I said at the start
of the video my friend Tom cui and I do
a podcast called
watching the Watchmen which we break
down the Watchmen graphic-novel
issue-by-issue and we analyze it on a
sort of spiritual metaphysical crazy
level we go really in depth and it and I
think lots of fans are gonna see
something new when they listen to that
podcast so make sure you check that out
thanks for checking out my video take
care peace